if you were to break down
the most corrupt families that we've
seen in politics
both sides over the last i don't know 40
50 60 years
who would you put on that list great
question
um i would say uh that um
probably at the top of the list in terms
of breadth and scope
uh would be the biden family um and i
don't say that
clinton yes i would say i would say the
biden family
um and the reason i would say that is
the size and the scope
in the case of bill and hillary clinton
um
they ran a very successful uh uh
corruption racket
um you know whether it's legal or not is
obviously open to debate
uh but it essentially involved the two
of them and they were tag teams so
bill clinton is president of the united
states his wife is first lady
he leaves she becomes a senator he's a
private citizen
but it essentially becomes if you want
to benefit uh
if you want some benefit from senator
hillary clinton pay bill clinton
and benefits will flow your way when she
becomes secretary of state
you pay bill clinton inflated speaking
fees you give them other other benefits
um and at the end of the day um uh you
know the clintons enriched themselves
the clinton foundation was corrupt the
speaking fees were corrupt
no question about it but what you have
with the bodies
is really unique um in in terms of the
scope and the breath what do i mean
in terms of breath um people know about
hunter biden a lot of people do they've
heard about hunter biden
they may have even heard of james biden
uh but as i point out in my book there
are actually
five members of the biden family i call
them the biden five
who i argue engaged in corrupt behavior
some of it legal some of it probably
questionable
but the point is five members of the
family have enriched themselves
um and they've been very blatant about
it um if you look at hunter biden's
career
um even when his father was a senator uh
he was a lobbyist working for delaware
entities
looking for federal grants well where
would delaware entities
go to look for federal grants they would
go to 100
father they hire hunter biden to do that
job
he's a lobbyist in other respects um
when it and when it becomes clear
that you have to disclose uh the fact
that you're introducing earmarked
legislation
for the benefit of a family member who's
a lobbyist
hunter biden is forced to switch
positions and do something else
uh when his father becomes vice
president of the united states
he because he becomes involved in
corruption on a global scale
and this is where i talk about the
breadth and the depth and what i mean
here is the depth of corruption
the corruption involving the biden
family it's not akin to
a you know a nephew of a congressman
who's trying to get a rotating contract
um uh you know so he can make an extra
buck
the corruption we're talking about with
the bible involves foreign governments
it involves foreign governments
specifically the chinese government
which is our chief rival on the global
stage
it involves corrupt oligarchs in ukraine
so
that is hard to beat as as as far as i'm
concerned
um so i would put the bindings at the
top of the list i would probably put the
club
the uh the the clintons uh seconds
um there is uh there was a republican
senator um
who has had three members of his family
who has been lobbyists
um i would put them near the top of the
list the name is escaping me right now
he's still in office
uh a senator from uh from missouri um
i don't know why the name is escaping me
i i would put him on the list i read
about him in my book on uh on extortion
um he would be number three on the list
um and then i would probably put um
mitch mcconnell and elaine chow
on that list as well uh for their ties
to
uh the the government of china uh in
their case it's not quite as bad i think
as the bidens
uh because in her case her family
actually did have a shipping company uh
before she
married mitch mcconnell before he uh
arose in power as a us senator
uh but there's no question that they
have benefited from the largesse
of the chinese government and that is as
a result of the fact
that he has softened his position on
china over the years
as elaine chao has as well